I come off the
stage and here Here Comes
Howie AKA your father and he goes uh
dice um you did some of my
stuff so I go no I know you know he goes
what do you mean you know I go I didn't
mean to do it but I was too far in and
he would do like things like roses of
red violets of blue I'm a schizophrenic
so am I he did a couple of those
and I go I know I'm sorry I'll never do
it again I didn't even realize till I
just started doing it cuz I'm searching
for material whichever comment never did
it again but what I realized at that
moment was when I said anything on stage
that rhymed it would kill and that's so
you didn't do his stuff again but you
took the concept I took the Mother Goose
so that was you that's all you Dad all
you no I always gave him credit for that
that gives me credit wow no that out of
that I started doing Little Miss Muffet
and I do a few more then I got the book
and I did like 20 of them where did you
get from what that wasn't from you
no no no but isn't that was from your
mother but isn't that amaz from what was
the other one you would do besides uh
Ros I don't remember you don't remember
I don't remember but that's what I'm
saying so I just started and it became
like this signature piece that to this
day I have to close my shows with that
because what's the most always does it
what's the biggest one out of all
those well the one they love to do is
old mother Hub went to the cupboard to
get her old dog a bone she bent over and
the whole crowd goes R took over oh she
got a bone of her own you know that's
the most famous One the kids love you
know uh you know Jack be nimble Jack be
quick Jack burnt off his dick oh
you know uh yeah there were just so many
of them you
know